[Music]
how Darion cannot be trusted
the mad Kings daughters will destroy the
realm we have an army a fleet and three
dragons we should hit King's Landing now
[Music]
hey guys Pete here this is my Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 2 trailer
breakdown
it will contain spoilers for everything
up until this point plus some
speculation on episode 2 so if you're
not caught up this is your chance to
stop watching so it's a short but sweet
trailer you saw it right there
it starts off with Yan Royce in the
Great Hall of Winterfell again and he
says a Targaryen cannot be trusted
and then we see Jon sort of doesn't like
that or he looks a little like what but
it's interesting because we know in
episode 1 Daenerys just arrived at
Dragonstone so what's interesting about
this to me is has she made contact with
the north or they just heard about her
being there we also have things in
motion with Sam at the Citadel who
wanted to send information to John about
the dragon glass at Dragonstone so they
could be talking about doing a trip down
there to get some of that we'll have to
wait and see until the episode airs but
it's kind of interesting that young
Royce is involved so much in these
scenes if you're cut if you're looking
at this guy saying I know who he is but
can't think of it he's from the Vale he
brought the Knights of the Vale there so
he's not a northerner and it's an
interesting choice that they've had him
have a couple speaking roles during
these meetings up north from there we go
to King's Landing and we see Queen
Cersei sitting on the throne and she
says the mad Kings daughter will destroy
the realm a little bit ironic coming
from her after she just destroyed King's
Landing but you can see her point of
view here obviously that's the biggest
threat to her power right now I scanned
this crowd here and there doesn't seem
to be any familiar faces it's what she
has left of local people that are
oil to the crown but yeah doesn't seem
to be anything too interesting in the
crowd of people that are standing there
after that we see the iron fleet moving
at night it's kind of dark but if you
look closely you can see the Greyjoy
sigil on a sail this would be your on
going out to collect his gift for Cersei
I would imagine we then go over to
Dragonstone and we hear Yara say that we
have an army a fleet and three dragons
we should hit King's Landing now in
attendance there in the map room at
Dragonstone we see Tyrion Musante grey
worm Varys see on a lot of sand and then
we get this cool shot of Dany where
she's thinking we see the fleet on the
horizon she sort of turns around we
assume here that she is going to give
her answer about attacking King's
Landing not sure what her thinking is
going to be here but we do know from the
trailers that were released that there's
going to be a battle at sea so it's kind
of like in my mind a setup of how Yara
and Theon are going to end up clashing
with you're on your own is probably
headed towards Dragonstone but that's
not a far way to go so not sure how this
will all play out timeline wise then we
get sort of the big thing that I think
caught everyone's attention and that is
Aria who appears to be shook and she's
looking at a wolf or possibly a dire
wolf at first this was definitely like
oh wow
look my Mira is back but then I actually
read some stuff and looked at some
things because it doesn't look like a
dire wolf you know like this this wolf
or Nymeria in general should be about as
big as summer or ghost was and this
seems to be a little bit smaller to me
so I looked around and read an
interesting article from Kim Renfro who
writes for The Insider and she
postulated that it could be one of the
smaller wolves in Nymeria SPAC I think
that's a pretty good theory of course
there's no way to know for sure but you
know this
Union was nigh mariya is such a big
thing I don't think that they're going
to skimp on CGI you know we've seen
these really impressive shots of the
direwolves the other direwolves I should
say in other scenes and this to me just
didn't other than the initial shock it
just seemed to be like wait there's
something wrong here
so that article I read sort of had the
same thing and they back it up with some
good thoughts and yeah I do think that
this is probably going to lead to the
reunion with Nymeria and I also kind of
think that because there's such a strong
bond with the Starks and there
direwolves even though you know Aria
doesn't have what she has in the books
in the show where you know she kind of
goes in and connects and basically wards
Nymeria and her dreams in the books but
it showed ever really touched on that
but they should have that connection
still and there shouldn't be any
hostility when they do meet up but it's
exciting either way we've all been
anticipating that that would probably
happen and this is probably the first
step in that direction if nothing else
there's a quick shot here of a woman
with a dagger stabbing at something
that's what you can see I looked at this
quite a bit and thought about who it
might be or where it might be it looks
like it's probably on a boat and if I
had to guess I would say this is tyene
sand because she is the sand snake who
uses daggers the actress has longer hair
than what we saw last season what I mean
but I think that she may have grown her
hair out based on recent photos and
things so yeah that's my best guess I
don't know if you guys have a better
clue on who that is but if it's the same
snake I think it's her and I don't know
who else it would be so that's my guess
and I have no idea what she's stabbing
at but I'm excited to find out and we
see this shot of the Lara and Yara
kissing which we've seen in a couple of
the trailers I guess we could think that
this is at Dragonstone or after they
left since we saw them both they're
together in the map room because they
keep showing us it sort of feels like
it's a prelude to something else but
we'll have to wait and see because we
just don't have that much
Meishan we do know Yara likes girls from
other things and Ellora is pretty open
to anything so it's not a big surprise
that these two would be making out we
see a quick shot of Baris giving what
looks like counsel to Daenerys this is
in Dragonstone I would guess as well but
not in the map room this is it from
another part of the episode any time
Varys is talking it's pretty enjoyable
so this will be cool I have no idea
what's going on here though they look
like they're looking at something but I
couldn't tell you what it is then we see
Littlefinger getting choked we saw a bit
of this in the trailers as well but this
is a pretty cool clothes easy to see
shot that he is being choked and it does
appear to be by Jon they do look like
they're in the crypts and there's
another photo that was released of these
two together this isn't in the actual
trailer but it's a set photo that was
released where we see them in the crypts
and it's all nice and bright like it's
not dark like almost everything that we
see from the crypts and we can clearly
see that the statue of Jon's mother
Liana is right to their side there and
that is where she's buried so there's a
lot we could speculate there on as far
as what he would be doing is Liana just
a prop here or is that his move is to
reveal Jon's parentage and if that was
his move what I mean Littlefinger
doesn't do anything without a reason so
what would the reasoning be for him to
do that either way he's there to push
Jon's buttons of attempt I guess and he
wants to get him shook and upset with
something so that he can get him to make
bad decisions that's probably the deal a
little bit of choking isn't anything
that Littlefinger can't endure and Jon
being angry and making bad decisions is
all to his advantage so we can imagine
that that is what's going down here it's
not like Jon's gonna choke them to death
or anything like that it's just a
warning at least I'd be my guest so I
have been looking at all the stuff
checking for Easter eggs and different
things so I'm going to probably do a
video like a list of things that we
might
mist on first watch that will be next
other than that I'm open to anything
before season 2 airs so let me know in
the comments what you guys are thinking
about what you want to see please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel because I'm
going to be doing a lot of Game of
Thrones stuff throughout the season to
go along with the twin peak stuff I've
already been doing check out my old
playlist if you want to see spoilers and
theory stuff that's all relative to this
season and follow me on Twitter and my
other social media accounts there's
links in the description and on my
channel that's the easiest way to get in
touch with me so that's it for now
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon